well you you built pink a custom uh
motorcycle this is amazing and I had
never heard of this maybe you have as a
push gift yeah what's a push gift those
are important what is a push gift no
what is that babe when you have the baby
you should get a gift
well you get the baby right you should
get a gift from a man whose contribution
do you have to push or it could be a
C-section this could be anything yeah
she got a motorcycle screw you think
well I think a lot of people kind of
look like a dog here in a high sound
when they saw that I gave her a
motorcycle but I think it perfectly fits
both of you that's different yeah I feel
like that I'm literally getting my
motorcycle license this summer and my
producers don't want me to but I'm
getting it and but I just want to know
how to do it I want to know how to do it
and I've been on like dirt bikes as a
kid but I just love that you gave her
yeah you got her did she see it like
beforehand did she know it was coming or
was it surprise not necessarily like so
that one of the common threads with me
and my wife is motorcycles I mean from
the day we started dating I said look I
don't do the passenger thing if you want
to ride like if you want to come on the
weekends with me and ride you got to be
on your own motorcycle yeah and through
our changes the weight well it's well I
mean I tell people there's nothing
better than to see the countryside of
the world than buy two wheels because
you're so in the moment you're having to
pay attention and you're seeing the
countryside go by and you're
experiencing in a totally different way
and so me and her like our Common Thread
as we've gotten older and different
interests has been motorcycles you know
like it's a great date night thing or if
like we're not speaking we jump on
motorcycles and go for a ride you know
like anything in between yeah you know
exactly get it out and uh so yeah so I
built her this motorcycle as you know as
a thank you for being an awesome mom and
yeah birthing my child yeah I didn't get
a present
um so well you brought the bike I know
that should have been a red flag so you
bro I honestly don't know that he knew
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks I'm going home